Mike Pence is going to have a CNN Town
Hall
but he's not a candidate for the
presidency so what on Earth is going on
let's see if we can figure it out CNN
has announced that on June 7th there
will be a Republican Presidential town
hall with vice president Mike Pence
what what you're going to do a town hall
with a guy who's not a candidate what on
Earth is going on and it even says that
Pence is going to take questions from
Iowa Republicans and Iowa voters who
will be participating in the Republican
caucuses but he hasn't said he's running
well there is a KCCI uh Yahoo life Yahoo
news report we never know who's
reporting this former vice president
Mike Pence lays the groundwork for a
2024 presidential run in Des Moines in
Des Moines
it is increasingly looking like former
vice president Mike Pence is going to be
running against the guy he served under
Donald Trump which is stunning now is it
unprecedented no there are a couple
other examples of Vice Presidents
running against the president they
served under I don't have them in front
of me but we're gonna if Pence becomes a
candidate we will look at that in more
detail if you thought that this primary
was going to get ugly with the entrance
of Ron DeSantis against Donald Trump and
it is already getting very ugly because
of that just you wait until Mike Pence
gets in now interestingly Mike Pence is
in third place right now right now the
Trump declines since the DeSantis
announcement continues the DeSantis bump
since the announcement continues Trump
down to 54 descent this up to 21 but
Mike Pence is basically tied with Nikki
Haley just under 5 percent
now does Mike Pence really have a shot
at becoming the Republican nominee I
don't believe so but to the extent that
Trump gets triggered by so-called
disloyalty you can imagine no more
disloyal action from your own former
vice president
then that vice president saying I
actually think I would be so much better
for the country than you even though I
served alongside you that I am going to
run against you so this is going to be
listen the set the town hall is going to
be Mike Pence not exactly electrifying
the crowd uh Mike Pence lacking Charisma
almost as acutely as Ron DeSantis and
the event itself is not really something
that I'm super interested in but but the
fact that it's sort of an event for a
presidential candidate even though he's
not actually a presidential candidate
really points to a fascinating situation
that we will be following
extraordinarily closely that's June 7th
Mike Pence I guess looking like he's
going to run against Trump just wait
until you see Trump fly off the handle
I love my Helix Sleep mattress I've been
sleeping on Helix mattresses for years
now which is why I asked them to be a
sponsor you actually take their famous
sleep quiz takes just a few minutes to
answer questions about your sleep
preferences body type sleep position
whether you have back pain and Helix
will match you with a mattress that's
perfect for you which is really unique
and helpful because a lot of people
don't know where to start when buying a
mattress I certainly didn't their newest
collection of mattresses called Helix
Elite come with a built-in glaciotext
layer to keep you cool at night an extra
layer of foam for pressure relief and
thousands of extra micro coils for Best
in Class support and durability all of
their mattresses ship right to your door
totally free they come with a 10 or 15
year warranty and you get 100 nights to
decide if you like it my audience also
gets a whopping 20 off all order plus
two free pillows go to Helix sleep.com
slash Pacman the link is in the
description